my name's Jake Knapp and I'm a design
partner at Google Ventures at Google
Ventures we invest in the most
innovative and exciting startups in the
world try to use design to make them as
successful as possible some of my
colleagues said oh my god we just talked
to one of our companies and they make a
robot that delivers stuff and we you
know the relationship blossomed from
there
that's a view we build robots for hotels
they do a delivery to guest rooms and
they do it completely by themselves they
ride the elevator and navigate through
the halls and deliver stuff to people we
didn't actually know this when we
decided to take funding from Google
Ventures that they had this whole staff
but then they started saying oh by the
way we have a design team that can help
you if you want like wow great and then
all of a sudden you have five designers
on your team for a week and it makes a
huge difference to what you can do we
did this sprint which is a one-week
process we do with our companies and we
worked on kind of figuring out together
with savvy ocala the personality of the
robot at work when he guest encounters
it
what's exciting you Google Ventures is
to get in at the beginning moments of
those great technologies chances are
with high probability you've never had a
robot deliver to your door before and so
when you open your door and you have
that interaction it's got to work well
and it's got to work every time Google
Ventures helped get us over that last
hump as we were getting ready to take
this thing out in the field and make it
really great